sri lanka's president gojabaya rajapaksa
and his wife have fled the country on a
military jet and flown to the nearby
maldives
it is believed that he left the country
before his resignation to avoid losing
his immunity and possibly being arrested
it's not known if rajapaksa will stay on
the island nation but his decision to
leave has angered protesters
his departure comes several days after
crowds stormed and occupied his
residence
they blame him and his administration
for sri lanka's worst economic crisis in
decades with daily power cuts and
shortages of basics like fuel food and
medicine
dw correspondent manira chowdhury is in
the sri lankan capital colombo manira
what could this move mean for rajapaksa
and for the country
well sarah i can right now tell you what
it means for the people i'm right now
standing in front of the president
secretariat uh the official uh workplace
of the president uh for the people at
least it means victory people are
extremely happy people i spoke to here
say they're happy that gotta be rajput
has finally decided to step down from
the force to the president but also they
do want him back they do want him to be
held accountable for all the charges of
corruption and mismanagement funds that
are mismanagement of funds that are on
him for rajapaksa as well it definitely
means that this family which ruled the
country for decades it will be uh almost
impossible for them to come to power in
this country again uh go to rajapaksa
has fled to the maldives as you reported
the next step of course would be to
elect a new president
and as you have mentioned i mean that
would really be a big change for the
country given that the rajapaksa family
has led the country for decades where
does the country go from here in
well of course era big task as i just
said is electing a new president
according to the sri lankan constitution
uh when the president steps down the
prime minister who is running
right now becomes the acting president
now the public mood is very much very
much against vikrama singha himself the
parliament is slated to meet next week
to elect a new president but till then
until that point it seems like ronald
rama singer will be the acting president
talk with us a little bit more about the
economic situation right now because i
mean um
the the dire conditions is really what
uh
has spurred all of this in the country
tell us more
[Music]
well the economic crisis of course
continues and one very important thing
to note is that the economic stability
will not come till the time political
stability does
poverty and inflation which are already
very high are slated to go even higher
in the coming few months the road ahead
is going to be very difficult but they
do need a stable government they do need
at least a functioning government
whether it's about whether it has to do
with the imf uh package the
international one treatment package or
humanitarian aid coming from any other
country
the person the organization giving the
aid will need a functioning government
will need a face of a leader before they
can actually give that kind of an aid
apart from that that the country does
need a very strict plan of action they
do need that restructuring they do need
uh to bring down the inflation and very
importantly as people are suggesting
they do need a very transparent model to
show where all the aid which is going to
come in is going to be utilized because
the public rate in the administration
has gone down a lot so that will be a
big task to deal with
indeed to avoid any further corruption
or mismanagement that will be very
important for the country dw
correspondent manira chowdhury joining
us from colombo thank you so much
you